bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rtl on commence avec vous
olivier marais tôt vous êtes donc à la
tête d'un bistrot dans la capitale
quelles sont les difficultés auxquelles
vous faites face au quotidien en raison
de ce pass sanitaires
aujourd'hui vous confronté à certaines
personnes qui qui ne veulent pas servat
xi n'est donc avoir le passage se passe
sanitaires et donc nous on porte
aujourd'hui le poids du contrôle est
aussi le poids de la sanction
et on les restrictions auxquelles on
exposer ne sont pas très claires voilà
aujourd'hui si j'ai un contrôle de
police face à une personne qui m'a
présenté impose pas faux pas sanitaires
et qu'elle ne présente pas la police ont
considéré que j'ai pas contrôler cette
personne voilà bien prendre à une perte
aussi de clientèle simplement parce que
on les autorise pas à s'installer parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de passé à lithaire et
à partir de
mercredi on va être confrontés à
l'obligation de nos salariés de se faire
vacciner moi j'ai deux salariés qui ne
veulent pas se faire vacciner
donc qu'ils vont devoir systématiquement
me fournir des tests on est passé pas
des situations qui sont très
confortables ça arrive régulièrement que
vous vous retrouviez face à des clients
qui vous présente un faux-pas sanitaire
vous arrivez à le voir s'il s'agit d'un
faux
pas du tout pas du tout parce que
partir du moment où nous on scanne
[Musique]
le qr code on va avoir un résultat qui
va nous dire
passe valide points donc mais on n'a pas
de vérification d'identité
d'accord et là on arrive à la fin de
l'été vous dites que certains de vos
salariés se voient donc contraints de
peut-être d'aller se faire vacciner au
lieu de simplement faire des tests
sanguins comment comment ils le prennent
comme on viens de l'entendre là dans la
manifestation de florian philippot oui
ils l'estiment comment se passer ni
terre comme un test de la honte ils ne
le comprennent pas
qu'ils estiment injuste ils ont leurs
convictions
moi je les respecte
à partir du moment où la vaccination
n'est pas obligatoire
ça veut dire qu'on considère que ceux
qui ne veulent pas
se faire vacciner ont font un choix
raisonnable ou raisonnée tout du moins
par eux donc à partir de ce moment là
moi j'ai pas tellement de solutions
d'autres solutions que de leur demander
de me fournir da partir de mercredi
toutes les 48 heures à un test un test
pcr eux
aujourd'hui c'est plus par peur par
certains le un parent par conviction
profonde qui ne veut pas voilà mais nous
on est on est confronté à ça et on nous
met dans une position
qui épate un pas très confortable encore
une fois on va faire la rentrée sans
avoir aucune visibilité sur l'hiver
les mois enfin sur les mois qui viennent
donc on va être encore obligé comme
depuis deux ans d'être dans
l'improvisation
nos politiques en termes de patrons
d'entreprises alors que nos entreprises
qu'on était quand même fragilisé par ses
deux années aurait plutôt besoin d'avoir
de de solides
prévisions voilà aujourd'hui on peut pas
les faire alors comment on a perdu la
connexion avec bonhomme et gardanne
combat c'est peut-être de retrouver on
continue pour l'instant avec vous
olivier marzotto est-ce que vous avez
constaté une baisse de votre de
fréquentation dans votre dent dans votre
bistrot à paris cet été depuis
l'extension de ce pass sanitaires
c'est assez compliqué c'est assez
compliqué à dire pour l'instant une
baisse de chiffre d'affaires par rapport
à 2010 neuf puisque c'est les années de
ses les années de référence
une baisse relativement importante
est-ce que c'est dû au passage iter est
ce que c'est dû au fait que plus que
jamais la capitale était été vis de ce
mois d'août ça c'est
ça je ne sais pas mais très clairement
on a quand même une perte lié aux pas
solitaire oui
est-ce que vous avez des craintes pour
la rentrée notamment si une de nouvelles
contaminations arrive si si elles
augmentent est ce que vous craignez de
vous retrouver dans la même situation
que vous avez vécu pendant plusieurs
mois c'est à dire la fermeture qui enfin
ça pourrait aller jusque là du moins des
restrictions voire la la fermeture avec
un confinement et de nouvelles retombées
économiques et des conséquences
économiques très graves pour vous encore
une fois
ouais encore une fois c'est ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure on est encore
dans l'improvisation la plus totale on
n'a pas de visibilité
comme d'habitude on est la profession
qui est
la la plus impactée par les mesures on
est toujours en première ligne donc et
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas du tout donc
on se dit est ce que si ça augmente
est-ce qu'on va passer à de nouveau un
couvre-feu voire des fermetures etc et
il faut se rendre compte que là on va on
va avoir tout les parisiens qui vont
rentrer on va aussi avoir nos terrasses
qui risque d'être d'être pleine enfin en
tout cas c'est ce que c'est ce que je
souhaite donc le contrôle va être aussi
rendu plus compliqué mais nous on est en
politique très tendu parce qu'on se dit
si demain on ferme on va pas embaucher
parce qu'on va on va se retrouver avec
des contrats enfin c'est c'est très très
très très compliqué voyez d'avoir une
vraie politique de ceux de s'imposer des
choses
qu'on n'est pas sûr de pouvoir tenir
dans le temps
merci beaucoup olivier mazet tout avoir
été en direct avec nous pour parler de
cet espace sanitaire je rappelle que
vous êtes patron d'un café à paris merci
à vous